hey hey there is currently construction
going on in my office so instead of
setting up an awkward camera in my home
I thought now would be the perfect time
to do a voiceover video I wanted to talk
about something that's been on my mind
for quite a while which is ideas around
the Joker film
yes I'm two months late for anyone to
still care about this but if you clicked
hear me out I wanted to discuss not so
much to film itself what's more
interesting to me is the reaction to it
and how it was portrayed and perceived
by the media and the audience in general
and now that the time has passed and
it's sort of come to a conclusion so
personally I was very happy when I saw
the trailer had come out The Joker is
already a somewhat of a subculture meme
so this led to excitement for more memes
but I was mainly excited because it
started one of my favorite actors
Joaquin Phoenix which seriously why is
it not called Joachim Phoenix English
language please I think he's a
phenomenal actor and I knew he would fit
this role just perfectly a quick side
note here is that in the previous film
that featured the Joker in in Suicide
Squad the performance was by Jared Leto
which was a questionable display
and according to The Hollywood Reporter
Lleida was fuming over not being casted
as the new Joker in this film and I
think it's so funny when people are
upset over something they have no right
to be upset about Leto is a good actor
in all but when you're sending allegedly
according to him use condoms anal beads
live rats threw people on this set I
think he is trolling when he says this
and the rule generally is never go full
Joker never go full butt when the other
stars in the film were asked about the
gifts they're clearly very uncomfortable
yeah did you get one yes I can't even
begin to tell you the weird things I got
I got a number of gifts to charity so I
don't like to talk about I guess that's
just what happens when you're so
epically immersed in the character of
the Joker on another side note I think
the fact that Jared Leto who previously
won an Oscar contrasting kwok-him who
never won one and clearly deserves to
there's probably many reasons to why he
hasn't won one but I think part of the
reason why it's because Joachim is weird
I've been meaning to do a video on him
just him because I find him very
interesting he's the kind of person that
you don't really know where to place him
and he clearly enjoys that and plays on
that but those kind of people are hard
to attribute Awards to and I think
that's why that's exactly the reason why
kwok-him fits so perfectly this role
anyway the trailer came up it all looked
great people are very excited but the
media's reaction slowly started to
become weird talking about how Joker is
a dangerous film bringing out the worst
of the internet talking about how
killing rampage would encourage copycat
attacks talking about its dangerous
message or insult culture male range the
list went on it went on so much that
Todd Philip the creator of the film even
had to step in and say publicly hey I
really think there's been a lot of think
pieces written by people who proudly say
they haven't even seen the movie and
they don't need to I would just argue
that you might want to watch the movie
you might want to watch it with an open
mind that's pretty fair
that you at least watched a film the
point here being people were sure this
movies somehow glorified insult violence
or even white rage was mentioned it went
so far that even during a press
interview with Joaquin Phoenix and the
Telegraph they asked Phoenix directly
are you concerned that the Joker might
perversely end up inspiring exactly the
kind of people it's about with
potentially tragic result Joaquim
walked out and left the interview and he
went even worse from here the military
the US military issued a warning to
troops about the premiere event it was
almost as if media was bracing for her
impact that something bad was gonna
happen but then the movie finally came
out and surprised it's a movie about
mental health unfortunately this didn't
change the narrative from media that it
was still a dangerous film but I think
what the movie seemed to have mostly
inspired was to have a bunch of kids
dancing at a staircase so was it all an
overreaction what had spawned many of
these headlines and concerns came from
what happened seven years ago in 2012
Aurora Colorado a shooting which took
place at a movie theater but it wasn't
just any movie theater it was during the
Dark Knight Rises the Batman film and
the terrorists had red dyed hair and it
was told that the shooter called himself
Joker
so maybe the media's criticism over its
film's release wasn't unfounded then
except this wasn't the truth according
to the district attorney it never
happened
Colorado officials have attempted to
clarify for years that the terrorists
never refer to himself as the Joker
quote the story has persisted because it
fits the narrative so cleanly of course
a crazy haired colored guy who shot up
the Batman premiere thought he was the
Joker of course and yet it has no
connection to reality the narrative
about the Joker association with
violence was false
the film's Dark Knight was targeted
because it was the biggest movie
premiering at the time there was nothing
more to it but despite all the negative
press that recent Joker film received
the movie was still a huge success
attracting ninety 3.5 million on its
opening which is a record for any
October debit film it became the highest
gross all rated film of all time and I
saw it
maybe the hype ruined it a little bit
for me but it was a really great film
I don't think the movies without
criticism is my point I'm not what Times
Magazine would call a staunch defender
of it but people have been blaming
movies games music etc as problems for
other people's behavior for decades
instead of blaming you know the people
themselves hell I've even been blamed as
well so why do we do this well it's easy
emotions run high it's hard to think
rationally you want an easy solution to
a complex issue but I would argue it's
time to be more responsible and look at
the bigger picture the reality is that
hate isn't going to stop existing I'm
not gonna pretend that I know how to
stop hateful acts from happening but
there are two things about hate that I
do know number one it feeds off
reactions this may seem like an obscure
example but during World War two in
Japan there was a big concern by people
that most of its beautiful and cultured
and valued structures would get
destroyed by the fire bombings I went on
in Kyoto were one of the most beautiful
structures resides which is the golden
temple was miraculously preserved
throughout the war but ironically the
temple was destroyed shortly after the
war ended anyway and it wasn't from any
war or bombing it was burned down by an
arsonist who tried to commit suicide but
was caught before and later diagnosed as
schizophrenic his motivation was to
quote retaliate against society never
heard that before right to me it begs
the question if the concern for the
temples protection didn't exist would it
still have been burned down Society saw
a likely event as a potential tragedy
and he came true just not the way they
had expected that's why to me the
concern for a shooting in a cinema might
take place which is by the way a valid
opinion to have I'm not saying you're
wrong to be concerned about these things
but it could be potentially a dangerous
thing to highlight just so heavily I
understand that it's not just one
person's fault either for addressing
what could potentially be an issue with
a film but since so many articles came
out prior to its release without
admittedly haven't even seen it it kind
of begs the question if it was all just
not pure recklessness my second point
that I know about hate is that it wants
to be recognized not every time but a
lot of times the movie actually depicts
this accurately an outcast a lot of time
one attention they want to be heard even
if it's a dying breath this is I think
an inherent Hey
trading people that wouldn't come from
any inspirational source just don't give
it to them Arthur in the film was lucky
to get on television as a platform to
get his attention
by coincidence by raising concern that
someone might do something awful you're
basically filling a void for someone to
step in and take the publicity it's
sending a dangerous message to people
that we are concerned something bad will
happen we will platform that bad thing
if it does happen Arthur gets put on
television just to be ridiculed this
performance on the show is what fully
transforms the Joker the irony being
that the media helps create bad people
while platforming them all while
simultaneously thinking they're better
than them kwok-him had every right to
walk out of that question